hello and welcome
to this video this is three minute blitz
and it's not with an increment so
three minute straight let's see
what happens got the dirty harry on the
board
i'm playing this without increment to
practice
for my weekly tournaments
or they're actually two tournaments a
week
so um and
tomorrow will be will be wow loop
we'll be having a five minute event
and um this essentially means it's two
and a half minutes because i will
berserk all games
as i usually do in those i think it's
the correct strategy anyway
this is why i'm practicing
this time control okay bishop g5
white can take on h5 but that is usually
quite a risky
thing to do let's see i'm
a little bit unsure how to actually
handle that
um take e3
[Music]
the other knight can actually take
yeah there is this sequence here with
bishop takes d5
i think i analyzed that but i have
forgotten the exact details
okay
take check check it's possible to do
that
[Music]
this i actually had on the board in a
game
king e2 i don't think i can play
more actively i have to grab this
now white is usually going queen h8 and
trade on d8
funny tactical sequence
oh i can white force the draw here
not really what i wanted to do
it's um
okay
okay that's uh
a bit annoying
okay do we keep this
i guess we do i have to adjust to three
minutes a little bit
three minute without increment chess
this is hanging maybe prepare rook c2
okay
queen h4 would attack this
pawn
oops i have to speed up here
39 seconds
three
well f3 maybe
i can take h2 though
yeah let's see what happens
queen a4 check b5
queen a6 i can take e4
it's a little bit tricky here for both
players
so i can take this this with check and
then there is the mate thread on e7
this is the thing
[Music]
yeah i don't have enough time
king here yeah there is a problem
there is a problem
this one i will lose on time i have
eight seconds that's
ridiculous
and maybe i lose on position i am the
queen is gone
that was not well played
[Music]
um let me have a look there he's playing
one of the
best lines for white okay 93 is not
critical
but let let me check so this one
and now i went for the capture so knight
takes
um i i looked at this in the course but
i have forgotten it
so this so after knight takes i can go
queen to b6
or queen to h4 s is actually fairly
obvious
something like that will give me pretty
good compensation
having a dual attack a double attack
yeah bishop d5 is wrong i guess
he had this this this very strong
sequence with the check
like here the queen h3 is strong
[Music]
and then rook a1 that's a really well
played game if we look at analysis um
he's probably um
i don't know if he made any mistake it
doesn't look like it
looks very like a very strongly played
game
with just one inaccuracy here but your
bite is already a lot better and my
my time is awful
yeah queen h4 and this this stuff
doesn't work but it's kind of
this is really annoying to play i still
had a minute though
so i can definitely put up more
resistance
so b5 is still keeping it
[Music]
to something bearable but white's
position here is definitely better with
the knight on d5
this is not an ideal outcome of this um
of this opening yeah so here bishop
takes d5 is usually
criticized by the engine i am i actually
really had forgotten
that i have to take here one line is
is is this yeah that's important
yeah and um
here i have queen b6 or i think
actually queen b6 is in the course
not entirely certain what i had in there
i know that i'm just not dropping h5
here this is
not just a pawn loss but i think i
confused this i had a very similar
opening recently and what
what is really a key is that he has the
check that's really strong
like if they have to trade queens um
this is nothing special
both captures are probably fine i don't
know
this this and king e6 i guess or
something
yeah king is six this is completely okay
yeah you you think at first that the
knight is going to be strong here but
it's actually not doing all that much
there is nothing to attack and i go g6
f5 and have a clear
idea how to improve this position i
think um
yeah the computer says white is slightly
better yeah maybe
but this is nothing that is in any way
scary it is i think more equal than
anything else
um it's a different story with more
pieces on the board
if in particular like my king has to be
here to do something
effective do a job that would not be
possible with queens on this position is
much much more annoying with queens on
as we saw in the game we had the same
thing with queens on
without queens this position is not
worrying me at all but
the way it was it was just not good he
could have taken here actually
because this is just not dangerous at
all
but um yeah well played by white and i
confused the
theory in my own in my own variation
yeah
thanks a lot for watching